Hello everyone, my
name is Kinsey Kornick
and I'm one of the family
medicine physicians
on the Jonesboro campus
and I will be giving
your lecture on the
viral exanthems today.
Here are the objectives
for this lecture.
We'll be looking
at the different
presentations of these
viral exanthems and
focusing on some of
the exam findings.
This will build off
of the lecture I
just presented on
clinical dermatology.
We'll also be reviewing
different complications
of these viral exanthems
and populations that
are at higher risk.
And then we'll look at
the different diagnostic
treatment and prevention
measures of each of
these viral exanthems.
To start, here are a
few definitions to know.
Exanthem comes from the
Greek word exanthema,
meaning a breaking
out. So an exanthem
is a rash that appears
abruptly and affects
several areas of the
skin simultaneously.
Enanthem is a rash that appears
abruptly on the
mucous membranes.
Morbiliform means resembling
a measles rash, which
would include erythematous
macules and papules.
In general, most of
the viral exanthems
are benign. However,
in certain high-risk
populations, they can
be quite devastating.
Treatment is generally
supportive. There
are a few antiviral
treatments that are
available and we will
review those as we go.
Diagnosis is often a
clinical diagnosis and
we will review when
specific testing is
available and when you
would use such testing.
A few key points when
obtaining a history
for a child presenting
with a rash is when
did the rash start and
where did it start.
From there you can determine
how it spread which can
be very characteristic in
some of the viral axanthems.
For example, So, centrifugal
spread is a rash that
started on the trunk and then
spread to the extremities.
Centripetal spread is
a rash that started on
the extremities and then
spread to the trunk.
And then cephalic to
caudal or cephalocaudal
spread is a rash
that started on the
head and then spread
down towards the feet.
Other questions to consider
are how did the lesions
change or evolve over time?
And then how did the rash
appear in relation to other
symptoms? Did the rash
come first or did other
symptoms precede the rash?
The viral exanthems
we'll cover today include
rubella, roseola, erythema
infectiosum, measles,
chicken pox,
hand foot and mouth disease,
****** simplex, pteriasis
rosea, molluscum
contagiosum, and monkey pox.
Now classically or
historically, the five that are
listed on the left are the
traditional viral exanthems.
The other five that are
added on the right are very
common and are also caused
by viruses and things that
we need to review as they
will be common presentations
of children in addition
to the ones on the left.
Let's start with a case.
We have a two-year-old male
who was recently diagnosed
with a viral illness
by his pediatrician after
presenting with fatigue,
runny nose, fever, and rash.
The rash started on the
cheeks and then spread
to trunk and extremities.
Today his 15-year
-old sibling, who has
sickle cell anemia,
presents with increased
pallor and fatigue,
and on exam they have
tachycardia and a
systolic ejection murmur.
Mom has a picture of
the toddler's rash,
which can be seen here.
Which of the following
viruses is most likely
responsible for both
children's symptoms?
With all of these questions,
I want you to take a few
seconds, pause the video
if you need to, and try to
answer these questions
before moving on and getting
the answer. That will help
to challenge you in terms of
what you already know, and
then also just test what
you're able to recall in
these case-based questions.
For this question, the
answer is parvovirus B19,
which causes erythema
infectiosum, or fifth disease.
It typically has
a mild flu-like
prodrome that can
last two to five days.
Then the exanthem will
appear. The exanthem
starts with a classic
slapped cheeks appearance, or
macular erythema of the
cheeks, and specifically
it does not affect the
nasal, perioral, or
periorbital areas. So
that is a characteristic
feature of this rash. As
that facial rash fades,
a peritic reticular
rash then appears
on the trunk and
extremities. How long
that rash on the
body lasts can vary.
Once the rash appears, however,
the child is no
longer contagious.
Treatment in this instance
is just supportive
and the diagnosis
is just clinical.
However, in our
case we talked about
a high-risk population
where parvovirus
B19 can cause other
presentations.
The one in our case is
where the parvovirus
B19 caused a transient
aplastic crisis in
a older sibling with
sickle cell anemia.
Other presentations are
listed and more More
commonly in adults, you
will see a symmetric
kind of small joint
polyarthropathy,
and then some others
that are listed there.
Papular purpuric gloves and
socks syndrome, PPGSS, is
a very specific presentation
of parvovirus B19, which
primarily affects adolescent
girls or young adults.
It presents with a very
peridic, burning, bright
red, papular exanthem
on the hands and the
feet. There's a very
clear and sharp border.
There can be associated
edema, which can
even limit movement
of the hands and feet.
Then you might have
other symptoms such
as fever, lymphadenopathy,
or arthralgias.
here are a few other
examples of the rash
that occurs with
erythema infectiosum
the rash occurs in 15 to
20 percent of patients and
especially in the age
range of four to 10 years
old is most common our
second case we have a nine
-month-old who presents to
your office with a fever
of 102.5 degrees fahrenheit
for three days decreased
appetite and increased
fussiness The exam is
notable for mild cervical
lymphadenopathy, and no
treatment is recommended
other than supportive care.
The mother calls the next
day and tells you the fever
is gone, but her son now
has a pink rash all over
his body, and he's otherwise
doing well. And when
we're talking about children,
when we say that they
are otherwise doing well,
that means they're generally
eating and drinking like
normal, they're playful,
they're acting generally
like their normal selves.
The rash that the
child appeared
with the next day
is shown here.
Which of the following
is the most likely
etiology of this
patient's symptoms?
So the answer to this case is
HHV6, which causes roseola.
Roseola presents
with a high fever and
then followed by a
macular papular rash
that presents as
the fever goes away.
The rash begins on
the trunk and then
spreads to the extremities,
neck, and face.
This is an example of
centrifugal spread.
Our treatment is supportive.
Our diagnosis is clinical.
And a specific note
about the transmission is
that it comes from direct
contact with saliva.
HHV6 can remain latent and
reactivate later in life.
In certain high
-risk populations, it
can cause meningitis,
encephalitis.
Another high-risk patient
population is those who
have received a hematopoietic
stem cell transplant.
In those circumstances,
you would use the
antivirals, again,
Ciclovir or Fosconet.
In these more extreme
cases, testing should
be done with PCR,
which could be from a
blood sample, CSF
sample, or tissue sample.
Here are a few more
examples of a typical
roseola rash that you
would see on your patients.
For case number three, we
have a female infant that
is born full-term via
spontaneous vaginal delivery
to a mother who recently
immigrated from India.
No prenatal records
are available.
During the initial newborn
exam, you note that the
child is small for
gestational age, has a heart
murmur, hepatosplenomegaly,
and a papular bluish rash.
Here is the child and
the rash that is noted.
The illness in this
infant could have been
prevented by which of
the following measures?
The answer here
is A, immunization
of the mother
prior to pregnancy.
This is a case of
congenital rubella syndrome.
In our case, the
newborn presented with a
blueberry muffin rash or
dermal erythral poiesis.
The newborn also
had a murmur, which
could have been due
to a patent ductus
arteriosus or
pulmonic stenosis.
The newborn also had
hepatospenomegaly,
which would likely
lead to jaundice
in the first day
or two of life.
The infection can also cause
cataracts,
retinopathy, glaucoma,
sensory neural
hearing loss, a growth
restriction like
we saw in our case.
Eventually, the
child would likely
develop an intellectual
disability.
Diagnosis in this
newborn would be done
by serology, getting
IgM or IgAG levels,
PCR testing through a throat,
nasal, or urine sample,
and viral culture through
those same sources.
Our case asked how this
could have been prevented.
Rubella is a component
of the MMR vaccine.
it is a live attenuated
virus. You receive
two doses in childhood
in the age ranges
of 12 to 15 months
and four to six years.
You get 95% conversion
after a single
dose, and you achieve
lifelong immunity
in more than 90
% of individuals.
However, because it
is a live attenuated
virus, one contraindication
is pregnancy.
Rubella in a child
will cause a viral
exanthem with a prodrome
that is usually very
mild or absent. This
could include a low
-grade fever, a sore
throat, or some malaise.
Lymphadenopathy
in the posterior
auricular occipital
region is possible.
The exanthem is a
very fine erythematous
maculopapular rash that
lasts one to three days.
Generally starts on the
face and then becomes
generalized across the rest
of the body within 24 hours.
You can also see some
petechiae on the soft
palate, which are referred
to as Forsheimer spots.
Transmission can occur via
droplet or direct contact
with nasopharyngeal
secretions, and as well as
transplacental in the case of
congenital rubella syndrome.
Rubella peaks in late winter
and early spring. Most
infections now occur
outside the U.S. or in under
-immunized individuals, and
the treatment is supportive.
Here are a few
additional pictures of
the characteristic
exanthem and then those
Forsheimer spots
in the bottom left.
Case number four,
an 11-month-old male
presents to your office
with fever, generalized
rash, red eyes,
cough, and runny nose.
He is irritable and not eating.
His family just returned from
a trip to Eastern Europe.
No one else in the
family is sick.
Parents first noted
the rash behind
the ears and along
his hairline.
On exam, you note
the following rash.
Which of the following
infections is most
likely responsible for
the patient's symptoms?
This is a case of measles.
Measles is one of
the most contagious
viruses. You are
infectious four days prior
and four days after
the onset of the rash.
Transmission is direct
contact with large
droplets or direct
contact with small
droplet aerosols. The
virus can remain suspended
in these aerosols
for up to two hours.
One infectious person can
infect 12 to 18 others.
After you are exposed to
measles, you will have an
asymptomatic incubation
period of 10 to 14 days.
Following this, you
would develop a prodrome
consisting of a high-grade
fever, cough, choriza,
conjunctivitis,
pharyngitis, and the enanthem,
which is called coplic spots.
This would last for
two to three days.
One to two days after
the prodrome, you would
develop the exanthem, which
starts on the face with
erythematous non-piroidic
macules and patches.
The coplic spots
will start to resolve
prior to the facial
rash appearing.
After this, the rash
will spread to the
trunk and extremities
within two to three
days and will involve
the palms and soles.
Diagnosis of measles is
clinical, but there are a
variety of tests that can
confirm the diagnosis.
Our treatment is supportive
except for in severe cases
where vitamin A and ribavirin
can be administered.
Another way to control
spread and reduce the
likelihood of infection
is with post-exposure
prophylaxis. This is where
IVIG or the MMR, MMRV
vaccine would be given
within 72 hours of exposure.
Some of the common
complications from measles
infection include
diarrhea, otitis media,
croup, bronchiolitis.
More concerning complications
of measles include
pneumonia, which is the
most common cause of death
for measles in young children.
This can be a primary
viral pneumonia or a
bacterial superinfection.
Pneumonia occurs in
approximately 6% of cases.
Encephalitis is more
uncommon, and it only
occurs in 1 in 1,000
cases, but carries
a 15% mortality rate,
and 20 to 40% of those
patients will have
long-term sequelae.
This encephalitis
is a post-infectious
process and is immune mediated.
Subacute sclerosing
panencephalitis or SSPE is a late
complication and quite rare.
This is where the virus
remains latent in the CNS
and reactivates seven to ten
years later where the
virus will attack CNS cells
leading to cell death and a
neurodegenerative process.
Measles is also a component
of the MMR vaccine. In
order to achieve herd
immunity for measles, we need
to have 95 percent of
the population immunized.
Here are two additional
pictures that
demonstrate the
classic Coplic spots
and the classic
measles exanthem.
Case number five is a
two-year-old male that
presents with two days of
fever, fussiness, a decrease
in appetite. They are
up to date on their
immunizations and their exam
is unremarkable. You send
them home with instructions
for supportive care.
He returns the next
day with the following,
the most likely etiology
of the patient's findings.
The answer is Coxsackievirus A.
This is a case of hand,
foot, and mouth disease,
most commonly caused by
the enteroviruses such
as Coxsackievirus A.
However, it can also be
caused by other enteroviruses
and echo viruses.
This generally peaks in
summer and early fall.
The transmission is *****
-oral or respiratory.
This is most commonly seen in
children less than
10 years of age.
The diagnosis is clinical
but you can confirm
with PCR testing and the
treatment is supportive.
Input and mouth disease
will present with a
mild or absent prodrome.
This can include
symptoms of vomiting,
diarrhea, or abdominal pain.
This will generally
last four to six days.
A low-grade fever can also
precede the exanthem
and ananthem.
The ananthem is
characterized by painful
erythematous macules
and vesicles.
The vesicles will often
rupture and form a superficial
ulcer with a red rim
and a gray-yellow base.
A younger child commonly
will present with
a refusal to eat or
decreased oral intake.
If only the oral
mucosa is involved,
this is referred
to as herpangina.
The exanthem is a non
-peritic, non-tender
rash that consists of
macules, papules, and
cloudy vesicles with
an erythematous halo.
The exanthem occurs
on the hands and the
feet, including the
palms and soles,
as well as the buttocks
and extremities.
There are a few additional
pictures of those lesions.
Case number six. A six
-year-old male presents with
fever, cold symptoms, headache,
fatigue, and a diffuse
peritic rash. The rash
started two days after the
fever. It was initially on
the trunk and then spread to
all extremities. Some
lesions are now crusted over.
There are also some painful
lesions in the mouth.
He is with foster parents
today, and they are not
sure what immunizations
the child has received.
Here are two pictures
of the lesions.
The illness in this
child can typically be
prevented by which of
the following measures?
The answer here is A,
vaccination with a live
attenuated virus vaccine.
This is a case of
chickenpox or varicella.
Chickenpox is caused by
varicella zoster virus.
It will present with
a prodrome of fever,
fatigue, anorexia,
congestion, rhinorrhea, cough.
The exanthem is a very
pruritic erythematous
rash that starts
on the trunk and
scalp and then
spreads peripherally.
The lesions will often
be at various stages and
will evolve in the
following order, macules to
papules to vesicles to
pustules with crusting.
Some buzzwords in terms
of describing these
lesions include dewdrop
on a rose petal.
The inanthem is uncommon, but
will have painful vesicles
that will then evolve to
erosions on the palate.
Transmission is
airborne, or direct
contact of lesions,
or transplacental.
Diagnosis is clinical,
but there is testing
available if needed, and
the treatment is supportive.
Complications from
chickenpox mainly occur
in the immunocompromised.
In these patients,
we would treat with
antivirals such as
acyclovir, valacyclovir,
or famcyclovir.
Examples of the complications
include bacterial
superinfections with
staph and strep, which
can lead to impetigo,
sepsis, osteomyelitis.
Pneumonia, which can
be a primary viral
pneumonia or a bacterial
superinfection.
Neurological complications
include meningitis,
encephalitis, or
Guillain-Barre syndrome.
Another example of a
complication is Ray syndrome.
The varicella vaccine
is often combined with
the MMR vaccine nowadays
as it is a live attenuated
virus that is also given
in two doses at the
same age ranges. It is
92 percent effective
after two doses. And because
it is a live attenuated
virus, one contraindication
is pregnancy.
Here's another picture
of the numerous vesicles
and crusts that you
can see in a child.
And then here is a picture of
the ananthem that can occur.
Case number seven, we
have an 18-year-old male
with a history of asthma
who just completed a course
of prednisone for an
asthma exacerbation. He
presents to your office
today for follow-up states
that he is having chest
pain he has no respiratory
or other concerning symptoms
on exam you know the
most likely cause
of his symptoms
the answer here is b
reactivation of a latent
virus this is a case of
shingles or ****** zoster
while this is less
common in children it can
still occur in adolescents
and young adults
Shingles will present
with a prodrome of pain,
paresthesia, and tense inching
that will precede the rash.
The exanthem is
characterized by erythematous
papules that will evolve
into vesicles and bullae,
followed by pustules,
and then eventually there
will be crusting that
can last 7 to 10 days.
New lesions continue to
appear for up to one week, and
while this most commonly
affects a single dermatome
you can also have an adjacent
dermatome affected for
example having both t4 and
t5 affected the enanthem will
occur on the mucous membranes
of an affected dermatome
this is characterized
by painful erythematous
vesicles and erosions
examples of this could
include the oral
mucosa or the vaginal
mucosa depending on what
dermatome is affected
The most common
complication of shingles is
postherpetic neuralgia. This
can occur in approximately
40 percent of patients
over the age of 60.
87 percent of patients who
experience postherpetic
neuralgia will experience
resolution by six months.
The specific presentation
of shingles is Ramsey-Hunt
syndrome or ****** zosteroticus.
This is where we have
involvement of the geniculate
ganglion and cranial
nerve 8. This presents with
a classic prodrome and triad
of ipsilateral facial paralysis,
ear pain, and vesicles
in the auditory canal and
on the oracle of the ear.
Other symptoms that can
be experienced on the same
side would be altered
taste, decreased hearing,
tinnitus, increased
tearing, or vertigo. In
these cases we would
treat with acyclovir,
balecyclovir, or famciclovir,
as well as steroids.
This is an example of
Ramsey-Hunt syndrome with
the papules and crusts
on the preauricular skin.
Another specific presentation
of shingles is ******
zosterophthalmicus. This is
where we have involvement
of the ophthalmic division
of cranial nerve 5.
This will present
with the prodrome
of headache,
malaise, and fever.
Once the exanthem
appears, you'll also see
associated symptoms
of eye pain,
conjunctivitis, uveitis,
episcleritis, keratitis.
One of the significant
complications of this
presentation is the
potential loss of
vision, so early diagnosis
is very critical.
We would treat with a cyclovir,
valacyclovir, or famciclovir.
This is an example of ******
zoster alphathomachus.
the ****** zoster
vaccine is indicated for
those 50 years of age
and older there are
two types one is a
recombinant zoster vaccine
and the other is a
live attenuated vaccine
face number eight a three
-year-old boy presents
to clinic on Christmas
Eve with refusal to
eat and drink since
yesterday he has a fever of
102.5 degrees Fahrenheit
and increased fussiness
you We note that there
are ulcers on the
oral mucosa and erythematous
and bleeding gums.
There is no skin rash.
This is a picture of
the child's mouth.
The patient's symptoms
are most consistent with
infection with which of
the following organisms?
The answer here is HSV-1
or ****** simplex virus 1.
A couple of notes on HSV
-1 and 2. typically HSV-1
causes cold sores and HSV
-2 causes ******* ******
but both viruses can
cause oral or *******
infections each virus will
cause more severe disease
if it is infecting its
typical location HSV-1 is
very common more than
25% of children will be
infected by the age of
seven and more than 30% of
adolescents will be
infected by 19 years of age
primary infections will
have more systemic symptoms.
The transmission is through
saliva or skin-to-skin contact
via the vesicular fluid.
How an HSV-1 infection
will present will
depend on the site of
inoculation and whether
it is a primary or a
recurrent infection.
Oral manifestations include
gingivostomatitis,
labialis, or pharyngitis.
Gingivostomatitis is
what was presented
in our case and
this is the most
common primary
presentation in children.
Pharyngitis is the most common
primary presentation in adults.
If it is more of a
skin manifestation,
some specific examples
include herpetic
Whitlow, which is
infection of the finger,
herpetic gladiatorum,
which is infection
of the face, neck,
and arms, which
is most commonly
seen in wrestlers.
Another specific HSV1
manifestation is eczema herpeticum.
This is where you have
a patient who has atopic
dermatitis and you have a
secondary infection with HSV1.
HSV1 can also cause
erythema multiforme.
Other presentations include
keratoconjunctivitis
or chorioretinitis in newborns.
The diagnosis is either
clinical or obtaining a swab
from the vesicular fluid
or ulcer and running a PCR.
Recurrent HSV infections can
be triggered by sun exposure,
menses,
trauma,
or other significant stress,
or decreased immunity.
Recurrent infections
tend to be milder than in
an initial primary
presentation in those that
are immunocompetent.
However, recurrent
infections can be quite
severe in immunosuppressed
individuals where you
can have disseminated
disease, encephalitis,
meningitis, or keratitis.
Treatment for recurrent
infections can be supportive
or we can also use just
as needed antivirals
such as a cyclovir,
valacyclovir, or famciclovir.
In those more severe cases
or in newborns, we can
use IV antivirals. We can
also use antivirals on a
daily basis for prophylaxis
to reduce the severity,
frequency, and duration
of recurrent infections.
This is a photo of
a HSV-1 infection of
the lower lip. As
you can see there are
grouped vesicles,
pustules, and crusts.
Face number nine,
18 year old male presents
with a chief complaint
of an itchy rash. The rash
started one week ago with
a single spot but has
spread to his back, abdomen,
and chest. He has no other
symptoms and he takes
no medications. He also
reports that he has not
spent a significant amount
of time outside recently.
Here's a picture of
this individual's rash.
What is the most
likely diagnosis?
The correct answer is
A, peteriasis rosia.
Fitteriasis rosia is
thought to be related to
HHV6 or 7. It presents
with an exanthem that
is characterized by a
herald patch. This is where
you have a single 3 to
5 centimeter isolated
oval scaly pink patch
with central clearing.
And then additional
lesions will develop over
the following one to
two weeks. These lesions
will be very peritic,
scaly, and erythematous
plaques that often have
a choleret of scale.
A buzzword that you
might see in terms of the
pattern of these lesions
is called a Christmas
tree pattern. The
spread is cephalocaudal.
Your diagnosis is clinical,
but if you are considering
tinea or ******** on your
differential, you can do
testing to exclude those.
Treatment is supportive.
Specifically, though,
you might recommend an
antihistamine or a topical
steroid for the itching.
Pitoriasis rosea will resolve
spontaneously after
six to eight weeks.
Here are two additional
pictures of pitoriasis
rosea. On the left, you
see the classic Harold
patch, and then on the
right, you see some of
those additional scaly
erythematous plaques.
Case number 10, we have
an 18-month-old that is
brought to the clinic for
a well-child visit. His
mother's only concern is a
rash on his neck that has
been present for two months
and seems to be getting
worse. The rash does not
bother him at all, he
has no other symptoms, and
he takes no medications.
Here is this child's rash.
What would you tell the mother
to expect regarding the rash?
The correct answer is
C. The rash will resolve
on its own over the
next several months.
This child is presenting
with molluscum.
Molluscum is characterized
by an exanthem of
discrete flesh-colored
domed papules with
central umbilication.
They're generally two
to five millimeters in
size. They're commonly
found on the trunk,
extremities, and face.
They are mainly
asymptomatic but
might be itchy
to some children.
Transmission is
skin-to-skin contact
or auto inoculation
through scratching.
Treatment is for
cosmetic reasons and can
include curatage,
topicals, or light therapy.
But again, these commonly
resolve spontaneously
over the course of anywhere
from 2 to 24 months.
Here are a few
additional pictures
demonstrating
molluscum lesions.
case number 11 a seven-year
-old boy is brought to the
pediatric clinic by his mother
with a three-day history
of fever fatigue and a
spreading rash the rash
initially appeared as small
red spots on his face but has
since progressed to involve
his arms legs and trunk
exam reveals erythematous
pustules mom reports the
child is up to date on
vaccinations including varicella
family recently returned
from a mediterranean cruise
here is one of those lesions
what is the most
likely etiology
of the patient's symptoms
the correct answer
is d monkeypox
monkeypox or mpox is a viral
zoonotic infection caused
by the monkeypox virus
which is an orthopox virus.
Transmission occurs via
skin-to-skin or mucosal
contact. However, fomite
transmission is also possible.
The prodrome consists of
fever, chills, myalgias,
and malaise that can last
from one to five days.
Several days after
the fever, an exanthem
will appear on the
face and extremities
and then exhibit
centripetal spread.
The exanthem will also
affect the palms and soles.
The lesions will
start as macules and
then progress to
papules, vesicles,
pustules, and then
eventually exhibit crusting.
The vesicles and pustules
can be umbilicated at
later stages, and the
crusts can be hemorrhagic.
One of the defining features
of monkeypox is that
the lesions in any one
area of the body will be at
the same stage and then
progress simultaneously.
monkeypox treatment is
generally supportive and
most recover without any
medical intervention.
There was an antiviral
originally developed for
the treatment of smallpox
that has been used
during a monkeypox outbreak
under the Expanded Access
Investigational New
Drug Protocol in the US.
There are two vaccines
available that may reduce the
risk of developing monkeypox.
The The MBA vaccine is
approved for both smallpox
and monkeypox and is made from
a highly attenuated non
-replicating vaccinia virus.
The ACAM2000 is a replication
-competent smallpox vaccine.
This is only approved
in the U.S. for
smallpox and is only
used in select patients
as it has a higher
rate of adverse events.
It however can be
used for prevention
of monkeypox under
the Expanded Access
Investigational
New Drug Protocol.
Here is another photo of
lesions that you would
expect to see in a patient
infected with monkeypox.
And that concludes my lecture
on the viral exanthems.
Here is a summary
slide that goes
through some of the key points.
I'd also encourage
you to look at the
additional materials
provided on Canvas.
This includes a journal
article, which is
a nice summary of the
viral exanthems, as
well as a study guide
and set of practice
questions prepared
by a fellow student.
Here are my references.
Here is the link to
provide any feedback.
Thank you very much.